yeah you want to bring welcome to this
rapid game
let's go forth the other cards again
some of this is screwed up why is it
screwed up because this is better right
I need to find some kind of setup maybe
I should just maybe I should just get
rid of the get out quick get rid of this
this thing there let me let me do this
real quickly I can do it like that
picture here and we get rid of this and
this thing we
maybe we do here it's kind of okay and I
cannot screw up the later analysis
so Bishop c4 let's get back into this
game what to do and lie to b6 is the
most normal looking move I can also try
to just keep it down with a 6 or c6
whenever the CAD cannot be bad and now
maybe d6 attack the center chest clone I
don't know probably what's this Arabian
or something okay Knight to f3 so M
knight c6 looks normal
check the white center yeah what is he
doing
ticking on d6 no okay well um I can take
only 5 now Bishop g4 no we should reform
doesn't look right sir special takes f7
I could play Bishop f5 though maybe many
go see 6
that's true is six looks annoying I
don't I don't know if I really want to
face this move I can take twice on me
five and then the crew then is queen is
on e5 I mean that doesn't look all that
terrible the ambition of five days is
exit I don't like that okay so I'm just
taking it 95 I don't have 94
unfortunately ambition of seven major
comes first bit of a shame you have to
really defend against weight sometimes
so an easy move here screen to d6 which
is basically I mean it's offering the
trade of Queens and it's kind of it wins
time a little bit if he takes I'm
certainly okay I mean I'm not better or
anything that's equal it's a bit dull to
trade twins habits I don't quite see how
I develop if I don't do it so let's play
this I want to I need to do trying to
either g6 or ecigs to develop my bishop
and as long as the Queen is only five I
cannot do that so okay so he allows me
to take this is interesting
so that pawn comes to e5 okay well
there's nothing special about that but I
kind of like this that I get the pawned
get is pawn to d5 I think that gives me
better chances to to actually do
something it's one of the key ideas of
course of the other coins that you're
kind of yeah lure this pawn forward to
e5 and then
try to pressurize it oh yeah Oh a I mean
okay sure
I mean this is something you can do my
porn isn't all that great down only six
but Amelia I could have played f6 action
trying to like isolate the pond well
anyway this is not a big problem it
really isn't because it doesn't help on
my development or that much I got g6
Bishop g7 coming okay so his night will
probably go to e4 and then try to put
some pressure on e6 and so on
yeah qi6 have to plan sooner or later
otherwise my bishop doesn't move
okay so c6 is more or less normal 95
yeah I mean I can do that but not sure
he can put the bishop on to e5 here
anyway make me move the rook but okay
it's not a big deal anyway let's do it
now yeah I have nice reform that was one
reason why I didn't play Knight to d5 I
don't know
Knights you form
the energy force is very okay I'm
attacking the bishop end porn I'm not
yet when I look through them
oh really okay
really
can you have seven more I mean what
about this bishop there I mean where
does he put it in the long run I can
castle along it's an interesting idea
that covers b7 as well let's do it now
I'm keynoted if it doesn't work why do
you play so quickly that's a rapid game
or classical game so Bishop g7 it's a
big long diagonal there okay he's not
yet not yet dropping serious material I
think yeah I move like b5 that will just
be the a1 will move and this is most
obvious oh let's do it
this also has the idea to play Bishop D
form
oh that's actually really annoying
so should be for over three okay it's
not day at the end of the world I can
just takes it to 11
b5 that has no square now I don't see I
don't see any trickery that that night
is just on a for why not efore okay I
mean can i play
I don't want to deliver Bonilla even
this no then look Li one should execute
don't want to give me seven the night is
no squares anyway
no boats go here
yeah bishop deform the only has one
check them I mean I can obviously five
just stopping any check coming
[Music]
let's save square and then we'll get
eight I tried to be more circumspect in
positions that are really completely
winning because I tend to relax too much
and things like everything wins which is
often kind of true but then I still find
a way that does not win okay so we can
take this first for sure cannot play
takes on b5 yeah so now probably take it
well be like actually taking it is okay
it's like you know g5 if you take
through on the second wins wins the
whole wins wins the whole thing so it I
guess
so wanted to see how to how to do it
check here I can also play a six a six
is an actual threat I mean this is
really a threat it's good
I can shake a couple of times this is
still threatening if I go a six he has
would be six again it feels like I mean
we should win but it feels like I am
eights made life somewhat more difficult
for myself than it then was actually
necessary really great at that
sorry I didn't meant to do that
okay but now I can take on g3 I know
actually actually acclimate there should
be four maybe I could have done that
anyway okay
but I hear I can take on G 3 would be 6
or take
anything was basically fine I think but
who won normally I thought maybe there
was somebody even simpler okay so looks
you form oh yeah chick it's just a just
a chick is doesn't do more the bishop is
not really taking part in this but if a
chick here Bishop H to a chick that
should be good so Bishop age two but
then come in this pattern but it's not
you to do the trick
King edge one Bishop f4 wins another
look or exchange and here someone
uncommon mating pattern but it works and
route d3 mate okay so let's have a look
at the analysis there so we had this
this opening a bit uncommon
certainly a something that white can
play it's a Cooper perfectly perfectly
normal setup so 9 f3 and Queen - II -
yeah so I think taking on twice makes
sense and queen g6 is also given by the
engine it is the most logical move in
this position the Queen only five is
kind of annoying you want to trade it
all you want to push it back so that
turn I gain a little bit Wow it gives me
tons of is in accuracies and mistakes
okay now I I feel I don't feel there was
something really really what I missed
let's say okay so deform I took it and
here yeah now e6i adult I don't think
this this is this is any good to be
honest it's kind of you can't do it
probably without being subset
worse or something that there's good the
upside is very very little I mean you're
not going to do much here the best that
I can do is maybe win Becky six but even
then there's not much going on so
castles g6 and Bishop f4 again adults
don't like it okay so Bishop g7
immediately what source recommended
never do this that's actually true it's
a bit more powerful c6 is a bit lame I
mean still it looks good down 93 kills
also bit strange allowing that to fall
and now look everyone yeah as I thought
he should move the bishop somehow but
yeah then I just take b2 according to
the comp
like if you go here and then Bishop
descended that was what I was thinking
okay now it's already a little bit a
little bit of long castles yeah b3 is so
it's just just giving away stuff should
play the bishop back somehow Bishop g3
or so then I will click here and he
takes e6 I'm a pawn up it's still some
technical work but it's pretty good yeah
and this is running enter into that gf8
yes but that cannot be a mistake
it's so pretty good advantage Group F a
desist believed to be better yeah
because of the bishop d4 threat maybe
even possible em but I never to maintain
a large advantage and this runs into b5
so ya basta mistake Bishop e5 was a
mistake okay Bishop g5 yeah it's it's
indeed true Ian I met you I take the
book yeah I can it's - five okay - okay
and so what the computer actually yeah
values as mistakes it's just slow ticked
a technical play instead of killing him
off immediately which is of course
technically true but oops some thing
might share it sometimes which is
technically true it is a mistake but I
mathematically speaking when if you're
totally winning it really doesn't matter
or as much and here there was made in
five yeah so I mean this line is kind of
okay I don't really think that e6 is
netting white all that much to probably
just develop normally okay guys thanks
for watching